first of all I want to get gage Peter on
the story so we just found ash that
keiji inafune a Kickstarter from back in
you know the summer of what was a 2013 I
think at this stage 2012 2012 me I was
originally we going to come out in april
of last year its release date was then
moved forward to mid-september and then
to februari ninth we've just found out
that it's been delayed again to earliest
spring 2016 is what yeah they're saying
that you talked to the dude you have
sort of eyes on this project from the
start what was your immediate reaction
upon hearing that because this has been
a really troubled project at teams for a
while yeah and keiji inafune a knows it
and he and he gets he gets a lot of that
stuff at least based on talking to him
like he he feels bad because people are
upset but he also feels bad because they
can't relate to what he is going through
as someone who's making the game right
was trying to do something that was you
know an homage to he wouldn't agree with
this but really it's like an homage to
megaman even if i'm not like megaman in
many ways but yeah like my first
reaction was man i feel so bad for the
guy because one again it's another delay
too it's something like matchmaking but
one multiplayer chilling which you would
imagine is something that not a lot of
people would have is there like right
we're literally just talking about coop
like what do people care we've well we
figured out these hurdles yeah as an
industry and I don't know that people
really care and for him to have to say
or at least be the face behind this is
the reason you're not getting the game
because we can't figure out matchmaking
it's just you know it's for a guy like
him who is all about design these sort
of like cold game features I can only
imagine like he gives a [ __ ] about like
really doesn't care and he just wants to
get the game out there and make the fans
happy and you know he said like for all
the [ __ ] I'm taking now I know once the
game comes out people's reaction to the
game will be what I actually care about
not all this stuff and they went for
nine hundred thousand dollars on the
Kickstarter of course it reached almost
four million at three million eight
hundred and forty five thousand and a
little bit of change and what do you
think this says again a bad Kickstarter
we've
there have been a couple of notable
Kickstarter problem you know projects
did not really they either didn't come
at it and comment and in the shape that
people were expecting it to be do you
think something like this when it's
another big game and people are looking
at things like Shenmue last year like do
you think that there is less confidence
or more confidence in the Kickstarter
process especially when a big developer
like this it seems to me the general
consensus is that there's less
confidence among the backing audience
but if you look at something like money
number nine it there was a lot of hubris
when they were sort of like making
stretch goals and like this game could
have just been a simple single player
experience and instead of kind of blue
pants like oh it's gonna be on every
platform is gonna have matchmaking all
this blitz is that because the problem
right because it kind of got too much
money it I mean yes yeah you could say
that and that's fair and what do you do
when more people back your project you
gotta kind of like you know put that
money somewhere and it just you know i
think the lesson learned here is is
don't go too big unless like unless
absolutely necessary and frankly you
know i don't think that Kickstarter
people need people running campaigns
need to offer more features from for
more money if they if they offer
something that's a base level this is
what you're you know giving us money to
make and people want to keep giving them
money to do it okay but don't think that
you have to answer for every leg
thousand or ten thousand dollars with a
new thing that's not really going to
make a difference because your core idea
is what people are investing in yeah
he's not [ __ ] like sprinkles of new
[ __ ] on yeah coffee jesus in the chat
saying rather the game be good and late
and then released before it's right I
think that's probably not a lot of
people would be as nice as that you know
we anticipate games we look forward to
games coming out in a foo name is
working on a bunch of other projects at
the moment what do you think this says
do you then start to worry about
projects like reek reek or for instance
or any of the other things that he's
sort of the pots he's currently stirring
if you look back to when kids unif when
they started money number nine I mean he
made this Kickstarter campaign he
founded his own company in concept he
started working with into creates the
team that he's worked with in the past
but you know has now sort of charged
them with making this multi platform
game with all these new features I think
that they are not
perienced with so he had a lot going on
by the time this project started and you
know was seeing a lot of that through I
don't worry about recourse so much one
because it's working with a larger
publisher microsoft from the start to
armature Studios is working on it as
well and that is a team that is filled
with competent devs in context to what
they're making you know I mean they've
they've worked on big projects before I
like Metroid Prime series it's it's not
edit our wheelhouse it's like you're
comfortable to put it succinctly and
elegantly theater thanks so much for
lettuce and what you think of this
honestly hey stay there we need to talk
to Mike about far cry but I want your
thoughts on that as well and I want your
thoughts as well on what do you think
about what's going on with mighty number
nine I mean it seems from us in the
price who cover basically anytime
there's a delay it obviously is big news
for us and Lobby would like to talk
about it it seems like this is just a
bad joke that keeps on you know the
punch line keeps coming and coming a
comment so if you have any thoughts on
this let us know in the comments and if
you've actually backed the game I'd be
really interested to hear what you have
to say please let us know in the
comments below